about 50 kilometers east of Sofia lies
the tiny mountain village of chicken
cheveux at first glance it looks idyllic
a second glance reveals the abject
poverty only about 300 people live here
life is hard because our pensions are
small what can we do with these little
pension for modern mother we can't
travel there are hardly any jobs here
the only ray of hope
many of these people see is the National
Lottery the scratchcards hold the
promise of winnings that would lift them
out of poverty all they need is a bit of
luck yogi Lazar off is the village hero
in 2018 he won the equivalent of 50,000
euros with a single scratch card he's
too can chavos only big prize winners so
far because there's nothing else there's
nothing in our country no laws the truth
lies in the lottery it's the only real
chance if you win you're somebody but if
not you're not that's all there is to it
you're gay sister Paikea sells the
scratch cards she's an avid player
herself I spend the equivalent of 50
euros a month on cards but I've never
won more than 75 cards cost from three
to ten euros apiece
not exactly pocket change in a country
where the monthly wage seldom exceeds
300 euros
[Music]
some people give up quickly when they
don't win anything it's a scam in 100
cards you might find one or two with
five euro winnings and that's all they
are just scamming people out of their
money they is for example the new games
company in Sofia Bulgarians are
inundated with their ads promising
instant riches whether on the street on
the internet or on TV as a big winner
georg ii ii got to be a television star
for a day hello sigiriya little the
analysis was providing after just two
people articles across all new games is
owned by a Bulgarian businessman the
director is Dmytro Ganis 57% of
Bulgarians play the lottery and in 2017
the company sold 100 million tickets but
none of the revenue goes towards social
causes as it's mandatory in every other
EU country even so again if sees himself
as a philanthropist
of course relax positivity in every
sense we can give people positive
feelings and help them have fun I really
can't understand how anyone can get
addicted just from buying a few scratch
cards to try their luck psychologists
plan and Dimitrov disagrees he has no
doubt the gambling addiction amongst
Bulgarians is a problem the lottery is
the stock market of poor desperate
people if they had a different
socioeconomic status they'd be investing
in other things the effects are most
harmful to young people I've seen
children using their lunch money to buy
tickets
jackpot winner georg ale Azeroth's luck
didn't last long he bought a house for
his young family but recently he lost
his job as an auto mechanic now he
worries that he'll have to sell the
house to get by I was so happy it was a
great satisfaction I thought I'd won so
much it was such a big deal accomplished
so much but things didn't work out that
way in reality I ran out of money again
pretty fast pensioner Arista Dimitrov
has never won anything at all but he
still spends about half his meager
pension on scratch cards he and his wife
dream of visiting their daughter in
Germany someday for at least a month
they can't stop playing now you can see
Munich annoys Rammstein that wonderful
castle in the Alps and spend 30 days
there and feel like normal people dreams
die hard in the village of tekonsha bo
wealth remains scarce in bulgaria but
the scratchcards reach even the remotest
of places